it's official singer actress Halle Baily
is earning her pines' Ariel and now
following a bit of backlash on social
media she's breaking her silence about
being cast in the upcoming remake of The
Little Mermaid as you may already know
Bailey is a 19 year old singer who
performs alongside her older sister
Chloe in the R&B duo Chloe and Halle hey
guys it's Chloe she's also an actress on
the hit show groan ish you practice a
little bit of it every day and you know
you can't get curl and life goals in one
weekend in early July the house of mouse
announced that she'd been cast as Ariel
in the live-action remake of The Little
Mermaid and the news caused something of
a stir on social media some fans of the
original expressed disappointment over
the casting choice expressing that
Bailey a black woman wasn't the right
person to play Ariel who is depicted as
having white skin and red hair in the
1989 animated original now Bailey has
come forward to reveal her thoughts on
the matter
feel like I'm dreaming and I'm just
grateful and I don't pay attention to
the negativity she added I just feel
like this role was something bigger than
me and greater and it's going to be
beautiful I'm just so excited to be a
part of it in a separate variety
interview Bailey admitted that taking on
the role is definitely a little bit
nerve-wracking because I'm the little
sister I'm so used to us going through
these challenging moments in our career
together but I am beginning to
understand that this film is so much
bigger than me this is the first time
Bailey has publicly addressed the
criticism but in July she revealed that
she's overjoyed about landing the role
it's really really exciting yeah I just
feel really grateful right now
still really in shock I just found out
like a day or two ago
unfortunately the backlash hasn't
entirely settled yet one fan even
started an online petition writing that
we feel that casting is a betrayal of
Ariel's original creators diehard fans
and small children the world over who
just want to see the aerial they already
know and love brought to life with a big
screen of course plenty of people are
praising the casting choice including
Jodi Benson who voiced Ariel in the
animated movie its sequels and a number
of television projects Benson defended
Bailey's casting by saying I think that
the spirit of a character is what really
matters what you bring to the table and
a character as far as their hearts and
their spirits is what really counts no
matter what we look like on the outside
no matter our race our nation or the
color of our skin on July 6 the Disney
on cable network freeform published an
open letter on Instagram firmly standing
by the casting choice the post read in
part the character of Ariel is a work of
fiction so after all of this is said and
done and you still cannot get past the
idea that choosing the incredible
sensational highly talented gorgeous
Halle Baily is anything other than the
inspired casting that it is because she
doesn't look like the cartoon one oh boy
do I have some news for you about you
director Rob Marshall also voiced his
unwavering faith in Baileys talent
telling variety she possesses a rare
combination of spirits heart youth
innocence and substance plus a glorious
singing voice all intrinsic qualities
necessary to play this iconic role check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]